si está siendo una jornada como decía es
ángela muy completa y con mucho trabajo
sin duda una de las más interesantes de
esta tarde ha sido la intervención del
nuevo presidente iraní ebrahim raisi que
atacó directamente a eeuu ha dicho que
las sanciones es ahora su nueva forma de
guerra y además no he hecho ningún
comentario sobre esas negociaciones que
están estancadas con las grandes
potencias sobre el acuerdo nuclear del
2015 raixi criticó también las políticas
estadounidenses sobre afganistán y sobre
irak hemos escuchado también esta tarde
al presidente de china xi jinping xi
jinping a quien ha dicho que repartirá 2
mil millones de vacunas contra el cob y
19 en el 2021 y además se ha abogado
también por un plan para luchar contra
el cambio climático de estación siendo
uno de los temas estrella como decía es
en esta asamblea general ha dicho que su
país dejará de promover el crecimiento
de combustible fósil en el extranjero
pero eso sí no ha mencionado el que
produce en ellos en su propia casa hemos
escuchado también al gobierno turco
quien ha dicho que presentará el próximo
mes el acuerdo de parís en su parlamento
para qué ha aprobado en el próximo mes y
además de los discursos que eventos
paralelos o sucedieron hoy con motivo de
la presencia de tantos mandatarios en
nueva york
sin duda lo más interesante angela han
sido esas reuniones bilaterales fuera de
lo que es la asamblea general que se
celebraba hoy en las tres más
interesantes más importantes ha
participado el presidente de los eeuu se
ha reunido con el primer ministro
australiano con el han hablado de ese
acuerdo comercial a que se acaba de
cerrar
bardem ha dicho que no existe mejor
aliado que australia en un intento de
cerrar esa alianza y el primer ministro
australiano ha dado la bienvenida a
estos nuevos lazos la otra reunión que
ha tenido el presidente estadounidense
también muy interesante con el primer
ministro británico boris johnson por
supuesto en esta reunión también se ha
vuelto a hablar de la situación de ese
acuerdo comercial que se ha roto con
francia a francia recordemos que no va a
asistir su presidente a esta asamblea
general intervendrá el el sábado el
primer ministro al ministro de asuntos
exteriores por el enfado y también con
ese apoyo que cuenta por parte de la
unión europea que apoya que eeuu ha
actuado por detrás y no ha sido claro el
presidente de los eeuu se ha reunido
como decía con boris johnson han tratado
sobre este tema con el primer ministro
británico también ha hablado sobre los
acuerdos comerciales y además también
sobre el cambio climático a continuación
en la presente giova y desarrollo
también con su homólogo iraní iraquí con
el ha hablado sobre el hecho de seguir
trabajando en esa relación bilateral y
sobre todo con muchas esperanzas puestas
en esas elecciones que habrá en octubre
que se que transcurran de una manera
libre y transparente